[Musique]
bonjour bonjour Alexandre bon ben on va
faire un petit tour et je vais vous
présenter ça c'est l cimen déjà dès
qu'on arrive là alors ce buste oui c'est
je l'ai présenté l'année dernière au Pr
mais étant donné que la priorité était
donnée aux femmes parce que c'était le 8
mars mon guerrier n'a n'a pas eu de
succès toujours aimé travailler avec mes
mains je faisais de la mosaïque j'en ai
fait pendant longtemps la Réunion euh et
puis après ben autre chose la couture
enfin et cetera et puis je vous dis la
terre la terre c'était vraiment quelque
chose que que j'avais vraiment envie de
faire
et et les circonstances ont fait que
j'ai rencontré j'ai rencontré Sabine
Badinier qui a été ma professeur pendant
[Musique]
ans une artiste oui si on peut
considérer qu'une artiste crée voilà si
on peut considérer qu'une artiste
travaille de ses mains ça oui je suis
une artiste dans sens là tout ce qui est
produit avec les mains ne sera jamais
toutes est pièces uniques et ne sera
jamais jamais identique même si faire
une copie ça sera jamais la même et et
c'est ça qui me plaît
elle elle est bien elle est assise elle
est elle est bien bien assise sur le sol
je vais vous dire c'était ma première
œuvre donc pour moi elle est très
importante et je l'aime parce que parce
que parce que j'y ai travaillé et que et
que elle a elle a vraiment un comment
dire elle a vraiment une attitude de de
bien-être voilà j'ai envie de continuer
de continuer de continuer tant que mes
mains pourront me le permettre je le
continuerai en amatrice ou enfin j'ai
pas d'autres prétentions mais mais ça me
plaît donc je
continuerai et
[Musique]
voilà